le suprême fasciste refait des siennes
il a à nouveau capturer une infinité de
lapin il émet à nouveau au défi cette
fois chaque lapin arrive tour à tour de
la droite
à l'arrivée du premier lapin le suprême
fasciste coiffe celui ci un chapeau
qu'il choisit être de couleur blanche ou
noire
ce lapin doit ensuite deviner la couleur
de son chapeau et il peut bien sûr avoir
juste ou tort puis un second lapin rives
toujours de la droite il est lui aussi
coiffé d'un chapeau qui peut être blanc
ou noir
il voit le premier lapin ainsi que la
couleur du chapeau du premier lapin les
lapins n'ont pas le droit de communiquer
néanmoins le second lapin doit alors
deviner la couleur de son chapeau et là
encore il peut avoir raison où il peut
commettre une erreur
puis un troisième lapin arrive à son
tour sera à nouveau coiffé d'un chapeau
choisi par le suprême fasciste voit lui
aussi tous les lapins avant lui et les
couleurs de tous leurs chapeaux et ce
troisième lapin doit à son tour deviner
la couleur de son propre chapeau puis un
quatrième n'a pas arrive puis africaine
et ainsi de suite et lapins peuvent se
coordonner au préalable avant le défi et
ainsi préparer une stratégie pour
minimiser le nombre d'erreurs mais ils
sont prévenus s'ils effectuent une
infinité d'erreur alors le suprême
fascistes les tuera tous réécrire à tous
les livres d'informatique en langage
fortran regardez pas les gars mais
est-ce qu'il ya moyen de relever le défi
d'une suprême fasciste que doivent faire
les lapins qu'en pensez vous quel pari
feriez vous pariez vous sur le suprême
fascistes ou sur les lapins
alors pour préciser la question va
admettre et si la thèse de church
turenne c'est à dire le fait que dans le
monde du suprême fascistes et des lapins
il est impossible de faire des calculs
que les machine de turing ne peuvent pas
faire en particulier du coup à la fois
le suprême fasciste et les lapins doit
suivre les règles du calcul ils ne
peuvent qu appliquer des algorithmes
dans ce cas et lapins peuvent-ils
concevoir une stratégie calculable
capable de battre le suprême fasciste à
coup sûr alors pour la petite histoire
ce paradoxe m'a été proposé par le
mathématicien yan shi faudel pour mieux
illustrer les enjeux les capacités et
les limites des algorithmes d'ailleurs
lui aussi à une super chaîne youtube et
ce paradoxe de chiffres dalle est
vraiment un problème super chouette pour
mieux comprendre les enjeux du calcul
donc je vous invite à le méditer qui tu
supprimes fascistes et des lapins battre
à l'autre les lapins pour ont-ils sauvé
l'informatique de la forte rend pokal
ips et bien si je
le paradoxe c'est qu'il existe deux
arguments qui ont l'air convaincant mais
qui se contredisent mutuellement
du coup je vais vous présenter les deux
arguments et je vous laisse trouver
lequel et palacio et en particulier où
résident l'erreur de raisonnement et on
va commencer par le premier argument qui
est un argument pro lapin l'argument pro
lapin repose sur la remarque suivante
dans un monde régi par la thèse de
church turing le suprême fasciste doit
forcément appliqué un algorithme pour
déterminer la couleur des chapeaux
attribués aux lapins alors certes il ya
une infinité d'algorithmes que suprême
fasciste pourrait utiliser
cependant cet infini et dénombrable
autrement dit il est possible de lister
tous les algorithmes que le suprême
fasciste pourraient être amenés à
utiliser
on peut commencer par tous ceux qui
s'écrivent en une ligne dans le langage
python ou fortran pour ceux qui veulent
vraiment se prendre la tête puis tout ce
qui s'écrit vent de ligne puis en trois
lignes et ainsi de suite
ensuite chaque lapin va commencer en
haut de sa liste d'algorithmes et si les
prédictions de l'algorithme sont
cohérentes avec ses observations me lapp
on va suivre la prédiction de
l'algorithme pour la couleur de son
chapeau
dans le cas contraire le lapin c'est que
l'algorithme qui vient d'analyser n'est
pas chez lui je supprime pas chic c'est
le règne donc de sa liste et passez au
suivant
et dès qu'il tombe sur un algorithme
enfin cohérent avec toutes ces
observations il fait la prédiction faite
par cet algorithme au sujet de la
couleur de son propre chapeau l'argument
pro lapin affirme alors que ce faisant
les lapins seront au plus un nombre fini
erreur vous voyez pourquoi l'argument
clé pro lapin elle fait que l'algorithme
du suprême fasciste appartient
nécessairement à la liste des
algorithmes des lapins maj on qui soit
le 42
milliardième algorithmes de la liste ce
qui se bat c'est qu'à chaque erreur un
enfant au moins un algorithme précédent
le 42 milliardième algorithmes de la
liste est barrée du coup et lapins
feront au plus 42 milliards terreur
avant d'en arriver et 42 milliards dia
algorithmes des likes met alors à partir
de ce moment là toutes les prédictions
correspondront exactement au processus
de prise de décisions du suprême
fasciste les lapins ne feront plus
aucune erreur
ainsi les lapins sont garantis de faire
au plus 40 2 milliards d' erreur ils
auront relevé le défi du suprême
fasciste et les livres d'informatique
auront échappé aux fortran pokal ips
convaincu peut-être pas si vite oui car
on peut aussi présenter un argument
proxy prime fasciste non pas et que ce
soit un argument en faveur du suprême
fascisme vous dire c'est un argument qui
montre comment le suprême fascisme peut
être garantie de gagner uniquement dans
le cadre de ce problème mathématique en
question je ne suis pas super mais ne
s'agit absolument pas de défendre de
suprême fascisme de façon absolue je
suis pas un pro suprême fasciste
bref j'espère que vous est ce que je
veux dire quoi qu'il en soit l'argument
proches comme fasciste et le suivant en
finale avec leurs histoires de liste
d'algorithmes les lapins ne font
qu'appliquer un algorithme eux aussi
sorte de méta algorithmes si on veut
mais ce méta algorithme est lui-même un
algorithme du coup le suprême fasciste
peut effectuer les calculs de cet
algorithme ce qui lui permet de prédire
la prédiction des lapins
mais alors pour faire perdre les lapins
à chaque prédictions il suffit aux
suprêmes fasciste de mettre un chapeau
de couleur opposée à la prédiction que
feront les lapins vous voyez ce que je
veux dire si le suprême fasciste c'est
qu'elle algorithmes les lapins utilise
alors il peut tout simplement lui-même
appliquer un algorithme qui fait tout le
temps l'opposé de l'algorithme des
lapins mais alors si le suprême fasciste
applique cet algorithme les lapins
seront voués à ne faire que des erreurs
et en particulier sans frais donc une
infinité alors vous avez peut-être envie
de dire que pour y arriver le suprême
fasciste doit connaître l'algorithme des
lapins et oui en effet mais ce n'est pas
là que réside le paradoxe
le paradoxe c'est que les lapins
semblait avoir une stratégie qui leur
garantissait la victoire or ou bien
d'imaginer un cas où la stratégie des
lapins et choix
mais alors qu'en est il les lapins
peuvent-ils vraiment concevoir une
stratégie qui leur garantit la victoire
ou est-ce que l'argument pro lapin est
fallacieux et il existe une faille dans
la stratégie pro lapin
qu'en pensez vous sur quoi parier vous
je vous invite vivement à faire pause et
à réfléchir à ce problème en particulier
notre raisonnement montre que l'argument
pro lapin ou l'argument pro suprême est
fallacieux je vous invite vivement à
essayer de déterminer par vous même
lequel des deux est un sophisme
fallacieux et en particulier où se
situent les erreurs de raisonnement
allez je vous laisse encore dix secondes
pour mettre pause
ok on va passer la solution et se trouve
que l'argument fallacieux et l'argument
pro la part non les lapins ne peuvent
pas concevoir une stratégie
algorithmique qui leur garantit la
victoire
est ce que vous voyez pourquoi le
problème réside dans le fait de lister
tous les algorithmes et plus précisément
de liste et algorithmique mans tous les
algorithmes que le suprême fasciste peut
être amené à utiliser où il car pour
mettre des chapeaux à l'infinité des
lapins à venir le suprême fasciste doit
s'assurer que pour tous lapin son
algorithme fournira une réponse à
quelques couleurs de chapeau donner à ce
lapin et du cou l'algorithme du suprême
fasciste doit toujours terminer quel que
soit le lapin est donc idéalement la
liste des algorithmes des lapins doit
contenir exactement l'ensemble des
algorithmes qui termine tout le temps
quel que soit le énième l'a pas à quoi
fait alors on pourrait se dire que ce
n'est pas si grave c'est la liste
contient des algorithmes et qui peuvent
ne pas terminer
il suffit par exemple d'enlever un
algorithme des convois qui ne termine
pas en fait si c'est un problème et même
un gros problème car au moment de faire
leurs prédictions
les lapins doivent barrer les
algorithmes et qui sont incohérents avec
les observations et pour déterminer
c'est un algorithme est cohérent ou non
avec les observations les lapins doivent
lancer les calculs de ses algorithmes
cependant certains de ces calculs risque
d'être lancé et de tourner indéfiniment
le problème c'est que pendant que
l'algorithme tourner il sera impossible
de savoir si c'est parce qu'il est juste
trop long qui va terminer mais bon ça
prend du temps ou si c'est parce que
l'algorithme ne terminera jamais en
particulier s'ils ne terminera jamais on
pourrait ne jamais le savoir et attendre
jusqu'à la nuit des temps sans jamais
conclure qu'il ne fallait pas considérer
cet algorithme dans notre liste en fait
le problème de la ré introduit par alan
turing montre qu'il est impossible de
prédire aygo rythmiquement pour tout
algorithmes de la liste si cet
algorithme va terminer ou non c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'un calculabilité du
problème de l'art est une conséquence
très bizarre de 7,1 calculabilité c'est
qu'il est algorithmique mans impossible
de construire une liste de tous les
algorithmes qui termine toujours
une telle liste est en fait incalculable
comme le nombre de taixing dont on a
parlé dans l'épisode précédent
alors pour ceux parmi vous qui ont été
bercés dès le biberon à la théorie des
ensembles
ça peut paraître très bizarre après tout
la liste de tous les codes algorithmique
et dénombrable un ensemble east aurait
donc envie de crier que le sous-ensemble
des code algorithmique dont l'exécution
termine toujours est lui aussi
dénombrable est bien loin ce
sous-ensemble n'est pas dénombrable
algorithmique mans pour mieux comprendre
cette subtilité il est utile de
s'attarder sur le cadre des
mathématiques dite constructive par
opposition aux mathématiques classique
avec ses histoires de différentes
tailles d'infini notamment en fait en
maths constructive ces notions de taille
d'infini n'ont pas de sens et donc les
intuitions dont on s'en fait via la
théorie des ensembles sont en fait
contre productive en maths constructive
comme en mathématiques classique il
existe des ensembles dénombrable
c'est-à-dire lee stable mais en maths
constructive
ça veut dire qu'il existe une façon de
lister les éléments de cet ensemble de
manière algorithmique un exemple de tels
ensembles dénombrable l ensemble de tous
les codes algorithmique
cet ensemble est bien lisse table de
manière algorithmique
cependant là où les choses deviennent un
peu bizarre pour un ensemble liste c'est
quand matt constructive il est tout à
fait possible qu'un sous-ensemble d'un
ensemble dénombrable ne soit pas
lui-même dénombrable dans le sens où il
n'est pas possible de construire une
liste des éléments de ce sous ensemble
et c'est justement le cas de l'ensemble
des codes algorithmique dont l'exécution
termine toujours ce sous-ensemble des
code algorithmique lui bizarrement n'est
pas dénombrable de manière constructive
et c'est là que réside la faille de
l'argument pro lapin elle réside dans
une faille des maths non constructives
qui du coup ne décrit pas ce qui peut
être fait en tout cas dans un monde régi
par la thèse de church curie mais alors
à moins de pouvoir écarter complètement
la thèse du flirt sur ring ce que les
observations empiriques actuels ne
semblent pas permettre dire que les
mathématiques usuels sont les fondements
du savoir c'est peut-être aller bien
trop vite en besogne
peut-être qu'il ya quelque chose de plus
fondamental encore comme peut-être
machine de turing est comme peut être
aussi les lois des probabilités